durante nueve semanas ahorre para
comprarme un juego que cuesta tres veces
lo que me dan para gastar los domingos
que parte del dinero o recaba semanas y
siempre ahorraba lo mismo vamos a
descubrirlo te voy a dar unas pistas la
segunda semana tenía dos tercios de la
cantidad total que necesitaba en la
quinta semana uno entero dos tercios y
para la séptima dos enteros un tercio de
lo que me daban para gastar cada semana
como el juego cuesta tres veces más de
lo que me dan para gastar los domingos y
lo compré a las nueve semanas ahorrar
ponemos un 3 en la semana 9
para saber qué parte del dinero ahorre
podemos tomar las pistas de la semana 5
y de las 7 porque son las más cercanas
entre sí si restamos 12 enteros un
tercio menos un entero dos tercios nos
da como resultado dos tercios eso quiere
decir que cada dos semanas ahorre dos
tercios por lo tanto cada semana ahorre
un tercio
completemos la tabla para saber si
estamos en lo correcto en la primera
semana tenemos un tercio en la segunda
semana dos tercios y para la tercera un
entero un momento pero estamos sumando
fracciones que pasó lo que sucede es que
la fracción que sigue es tres tercios y
eso es lo mismo que un entero sigamos en
la cuarta semana ahorre un entero y un
tercio para la quinta un entero y dos
tercios en la sexta dos enteros que es
igual a seis tercios y en la séptima
semana dos enteros un tercio
en la octava semana dos enteros y dos
tercios y por último en la novena semana
tres enteros que son igual a exacto a
nueve tercios perfecto
descubrimos que cada semana ahorre un
tercio de dinero que me daban para
gastar lo que acabamos de hacer en el
ejercicio anterior fue completar una
sucesión sumando de un tercio en un
tercio entonces el patrón es un tercio
mira cómo se fue formando en las
sucesiones de fracciones el patrón de
cambio puede aumentar o disminuir
veamos rápido unos ejemplos en la
siguiente sucesión cinco enteros
nueve medios
cuatro enteros
siete medios
y tres enteros que número sigue en este
ejercicio también tenemos enteros y
fracciones pero no dejes que te asusten
hay una manera rápida de descubrir el
patrón
pongamos atención en los enteros tenemos
5 4 3
quiere decir que cada dos posiciones hay
un entero - así que puedo pensar que por
cada posición es ir restando la mitad de
uno que es un medio
ahora veamos las fracciones tenemos
nueve medios y siete medios quiere decir
que en dos posiciones tenemos una
diferencia de dos medios o un entero
ya identificarse el patrón si en dos
posiciones tenemos una diferencia de un
entero quiere decir que por cada
posición disminuye la mitad de uno o sea
un medio
comprobemos lo anterior
5 enteros son igual a cuantos medios así
es 10 medios menos un medio son 9 medios
- un medio son ocho medios que no
enteros es igual a 48 medios menos un
medio es igual a 7 medios menos un medio
es igual a seis medios o tres enteros
por último restamos un medio a seis
medios y nos quedan cinco medios por lo
que ese es nuestro siguiente elemento de
la sucesión que las sucesiones de
fracciones no te sorprendan sigue
practicando y encontrando patrones
éxitos